a chill wind in the Essex New Town of
Harlow it was conservative MP says his
constituents are frightened about their
bills mortgages and livelihoods I worry
that over the past few weeks the
government has looked like a libertarian
jihadists
and and treated the whole country as a
kind of laboratory mice in which to
carry out kind of ultra Ultra free
market
experiments and this is not where the
where the country is there's been one
horror story after another as well as
frightened voters here are angry too
it's terrible don't trust her policies
at all she's changed her mind about a
lot of things it does concern me yeah
because I don't think she's got a clue
to be honest with you no I'm not scared
but I do think that this country can do
better after claims that the new
Chancellor is now more powerful than
Liv's trust he was asked if he or the PM
is in charge the premise is in charge
she has changed uh the way we're going
to get there she hasn't changed the
destination which is to get the country
growing
as the pair met at Checkers Mr Hunt was
being tipped to rip up another of the
PM's pledges and scrap plans to bring
forward a wampy cut in income tax
with some back benches already publicly
calling for the prime minister to go
Tori MPS will return to Westminster
after taking soundings in their
constituencies this weekend and the
plotting to remove her will gather Pace
making her position perilous
some MPS are already claiming the game's
up for the PM we need to have uh
confidence uh at the top at the at the
very top and I fear uh that Liz trust
now is almost impossible for her to
carry that conference either with her
colleagues or with the country a
challenge now would require the 1922
committee to change a rule that protects
a leader for a year 22 could change the
rules but they will only do so if it is
clear that an overwhelming majority of
the party wish us to do do that and uh I
don't think we're anywhere near that at
the present time
and Sky News has been told the defense
secretary Ben Wallace touted as a Unity
candidate to succeed must trust is
focused on Ukraine and believes damaging
stability would lead to a deserved spell
in opposition
but the PM's tax cuts have been
criticized by the UK's closest Ally I
wasn't the only one that thought it was
a mistake the idea of
cutting taxes on the super wealthy at a
time when
anyway I just think that I I disagree
with the policy but that's up to Great
Britain to make that judgment not only
although Mr Hunt insists the prime
minister is in charge MPS believe he's
now a backseat driver John Craig Sky
News